[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the AIDS epidemic Mike schlau
tweets the disease dominated the news in
the 80s and 90s how far have we come
since then well Mike tonight Mike
Emanuel has some answers America faces a
disease that is fatal and spreading and
this calls for urgency not panic
there was a time back in the 1980s when
a diagnosis of HIV was a death sentence
the median survival was about a year to
a year and a half which meant that 50%
of my patients would be dead in a year
to a year and a half more than
thirty-five years later it's rare to
hear about the virus even though more
than 1.1 million people are living in
the u.s. with HIV today one of the
highest profile survivors is basketball
great Magic Johnson who stunned the
world with this announcement back in
1991 and sometimes we think well only
gay people can get it only but it's not
going to happen to me and I am saying
that it can happen to anybody even
Johnson happen dr. Anthony Fauci has
advised five presidents on HIV AIDS and
other global health issues in 1996 that
was the watershed moment when the
combinations of drugs was shown to
decrease the level of virus to below
detectable levels and to keep them there
in 2003 President George W Bush launched
the President's Emergency Plan for AIDS
relief or PEPFAR recognizing the HIV
AIDS pandemic threatened to wipe out an
entire generation in Africa seldom has
history offered a greater opportunity to
do so much for so many
we have confronted and will continue to
confront hiv/aids in our own country and
to meet a severe and urgent crisis
abroad tonight I propose the Emergency
Plan for AIDS relief rockstar Bono from
the band u2 gave mr. Bush credit for
saving millions of lives and experts say
the investment has delivered entire
communities were decimated children were
living without mothers and fathers
schools went without teachers hospitals
went without nurses and doctors and
today in these same areas we have nearly
13 million people on treatment because
of PEPFAR before leaving office
President Obama noted the incredible
tools available to treat and prevent
infection what once seemed like an
impossible dream the dream of an
aids-free generation is within our grasp
dr. Fauci says the United States must
continue to lead because the fight isn't
over yet the final holy grail that we're
working very hard on is an HIV vaccine
so if you look at everything that's
happened from 1981 to today in 2018 if
we get that vaccine that would be the
nail in the coffin of HIV in Washington
Mike Emanuel Fox News